[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
funny thing about the chrono pandemic
for so long we knew very little now we
know
an awful lot it's now clear that in the
earliest days of the chronovirus
pandemic public health officials in
washington were panicked
at the time as you'll remember it was
not clear what the mortality rate from
the virus would turn out to be
but that was not their main concern
officials in washington were terrified
for themselves
they were afraid of being exposed they
had used american tax dollars to fund
reckless experiments in china that in
the end likely created
covid19 if that fact were to become
public it would be over
they'd be shamed and ridiculed possibly
even indicted
their professional lives would be done
so they immediately set to work
hiding it on a cover-up last winter a
group of well-known scientists publicly
dismissed the lab leak theory in a
letter to the lancet
as absurd and categorically untrue
and yet at the same time they wrote
emails to each other conceding that
actually the virus did look engineered
by human hands in a lab meanwhile tony
fauci worked on censorship
facts she made certain that the
self-appointed fact checkers who control
the flowing for information in this
country
shut down anyone who dared challenge the
official story which again we now know
was a lie
in the final days of the last
administration the state department
finally began a serious investigation
into the origins of kovit into what was
happening at the wuhan institute of
virology
but almost immediately after the
election joe biden shut it down
so in all the lying went on unimpeded
for a year and a half
and we're just learning now how deep it
went the informed consent action network
a group that advocates for transparency
in vaccines
has just obtained thousands of new
emails to and from
tony fauci they show among other things
that fauci knew perfectly well that his
own directives often had no basis in
science
for example in february of last year
tony fauci told us
in public that the covet outbreak could
go one of two ways
it would either be a catastrophic
pandemic that's what we're all worried
about
or it could very well turn out to be
just an unusually bad
flu season those were the options
if it continues to evolve into what we
hope it doesn't namely a pandemic
flu it will be very much like a really
really bad flu season
or a moderately bad pandemic season
so it could be a pandemic or just a bad
flu which one would it turn out to be
at least one reporter asked him that in
an email he's a man called john lepouk
the chief medical correspondent at cbs
news on february 16th of last year
lapuka asked fauci just how dangerous
coveted 19 was what were the numbers on
it at that time you'll remember fauci
was telling the public not to wear masks
he was telling reporters it was fine to
attend political rallies
public gatherings were okay fauci
responded to lepuk by outlining the
conditions that would make
him change his mind and demand lockdowns
quote
the current mortality of covet 19 is
about 2 percent
however there are several folds more
cases than our
that are coming to the official
attention of health authorities in other
words
asymptomatic or minimally symptomatic
infections if you count these
the case fatality rate could drop to one
percent or even half a percent or
less if that is the case then this would
be a very severe flu season
0.2 to point four percent regular flu
season is point one percent
or a typical pandemic like 1957 or 1968
half a percent to 0.9 percent we're not
sure where this is going to land
so it's interesting to note that tony
fauci used the term
case fatality rate in the email that
means the number of deaths divided by
confirmed
covet 19 cases confirmed meaning people
who have gone to the doctor
usually died in a hospital but then
fauci starts talking about the infection
fatality rate that includes the total
estimated amount of covid19 infections
in the country including ones with no
symptoms
that is a far more meaningful number
particularly if you're trying to make
health policy for the entire
country you should calculate how many
people who have the virus are dying from
it
so what is that number what is the
actual death rate from covid
well at the height of the outbreak in
late may the cdc's
best estimate for the fatality rate for
people with coven 19
symptoms just the ones with symptoms was
0.4 percent
that estimate was contained in the cdc
document called covid19 pandemic
planning scenarios
it was intended for hospitals it was not
in a public press release
reason magazine got a copy of it j.p
morgan looked at the data and came to
pretty much the same conclusion
infection fatality rates in the spring
of 2020 the height of the pandemic
were .06 percent in santa clara
california they were the same in los
angeles they were
0.18 percent in miami-dade county
in other words by tony fauci's own
definition
what we were experiencing was
effectively a severe flu season
at the worst but that's not what fauci
said
under oath when he testified at a house
oversight hearing in march of last year
in that hearing fauci claimed the covet
19 infection mortality rate
was around one percent which fauci
explained means it's quote
10 times more lethal than the seasonal
flu
that's untrue that's a lie it turns out
it's hard to think of a more misleading
use of numbers
in fact survival rates for coveted 19
for anyone under the age of 70 turned
out to be north
of 99.5 percent fauci knew that
on march 16 someone related a question
for fauci that a fox news anchor steve
hilton
had asked on the air here it is quote
given the relative safety of all but the
elderly and those whose immune systems
are compromised
why not quarantine only them
fauci's response stay tuned period
so we did and the next few weeks fauci
said
shut the country down he encouraged
closing down schools
even though as he wrote in one february
email quote children have a
very low rate of infection he knew that
but he pushed to close schools anyway
then he told
everyone in the country to wear masks
even though he knew they didn't work
as he explained in another february
email which we're just now getting quote
the typical mask you buy in the
drugstore is not really effective in
keeping out virus which is small
enough to pass through the material end
quote
those drugstore masks don't work but
fauci continued to demand that you wear
those drugstore masks he continued to
demand that the lockdown continue
why did he do that when he knew and we
know for certain now we can prove it
because we have the emails
he knew those were not recommendations
grounded in science
but he pushed them anyway why we can't
say for certain
we do know the effect of these
recommendations was a kind of medical
martial law
the country was so miserable and so off
balanced for so
long that no one really thought to ask
where did this virus come from
but fauci knew where it came from here
he is in 2018 celebrating the end of the
federal moratorium
on american taxpayer funding of gain of
function research
nih lifts funding pours on gain to
function
research so let me explain this a little
because whenever
the pushing back and forth from the
press so like
nih now is going to do dangerous
research no actual matter of fact it's
exactly the opposite so a framework
has been now established to guide
funding decisions on proposed research
that might be anticipated to create
transfer or use
enhanced potential pandemic pathogens
i'm going to speak slowly now for those
of you who are not scientifically
literate for the dumb people in the
audience which is everyone but me
the nih is not going to conduct
dangerous experiments
there's a framework that was fauci's
promise and in fact it was half
true nih did not conduct dangerous
experiments the nih tony fought she paid
for the chinese to conduct
dangerous experiments and they did
there's no debate about that now
it happened so what are the consequences
going to be
what happens if you do something like
this and
wreck the country will fouchy face
any consequences the white house
answered that question today
well i think we've spoken to this pretty
extensively from here let me just say on
dr fauci and his emails he's also spoken
to this many many times over the last
over the course of the last few days and
we'll let him speak for himself
and he's been an undeniable asset in our
country's pandemic
response but it's obviously not that
advantageous for me to relitigate the
substance of emails from 17 months ago
he can speak for himself he's always got
a place on nicole wallace's show or
she'll tell him what a great man he is
really kind of a hero he can speak for
himself on msnbc
so nothing's going to happen in tony
fouch he's not even going to lose his
job
ever as biden flack explained today he
will
never be fired watch this just since you
mentioned dr thought you again can you
imagine any circumstance where president
biden would ever
fire him no go ahead
no no and not only is he never going to
be fired
held to account for this forced to
explain he's also never going to
apologize
because it's your fault